when ebola hit the eastern part of the
drc in 2019
aid workers many from the world health
organization were supposed to be saving
lives
but reports have emerged that some
allegedly offered jobs in exchange for
sex
exploiting women who needed work over 70
women accused the humanitarians of
sexual exploitation
sexual assault and even rape dw's east
africa correspondent marielle muller
sent us this report about new cases that
have emerged from the city of bhutembo
the two women whose accounts were about
to hear did not want to be fully
identified
desanja has to be mother to those her
sister left behind
she blames a wh who doctor for her
sister pandesa's death
that doctor promised my sister a job
saying that they would be working
together
and that is when my sister pandesa got
pregnant even before she started working
with that the problem began he turned
his phone off
pendesa needed to hide her situation
from her husband
who was working away from home she
decided to have an abortion
that's risky in drc and things
went wrong
she went to the hospital at that time we
could not accompany her because of ebola
when she got there she did not even
spend the night they didn't treat her
and she was taken to the ebola camp
the doctors assumed her bleeding was
ebola not a botched abortion
she died that night and was buried like
an ebola victim
isolated from her family her husband
never returned
disorge struggles to provide for the
three children
she blames the who worker who abandoned
her sister
he should be arrested
this woman's story is similar but she
survived
we'll call her masika he told me he was
a doctor
working for the ebola response team
she had three children and no job so she
took his offer of work as a cleaner
in exchange for sex but he got her
pregnant
and pressured her to have an abortion
i got the abortion because it was a
difficult situation in my life
he told me i did not come here to build
a family but to work
for me it was a situation of life and
death
the doctor blocked her calls her family
threw her out
now she's rebuilding her life alone
this group is breaking a taboo by
talking about how contacts between eight
workers
and local women can end they say it's
sexual exploitation
an abuse of wealth and power
now a woman knows that a humanitarian is
not allowed to abuse her
she has a helpline she can call if the
person is not punished the woman can be
psychologically troubled
and can't return to her normal life
the who has launched an investigation
into media reports of dozens of
exploitative relationships between its
staff
and local women it said it could not
talk with us until the investigation is
complete
disorg says her whole family was
betrayed by those
sent to help who
should take steps so that others can see
it and they don't repeat this stupid
behavior
because these are serious issues
for more on this story we've invited
journalist robert flumerfeldt
onto the show he joins us now from
bukavu
south kibel province in drc welcome to
dw news
africa robert you worked on the story
as well you broke the story actually how
did you
discover these abuse cases
well um myself and a number of other
journalists who had been working
in the zone of the ebola response pretty
close to since the beginning i had been
talking to community members about
reasons for their resentment toward the
ebola response people would describe
things like militarization and
corruption
but a common refrain that a lot of
people heard was that oh you know the
responders would come in with all their
money and they treat us all like
prostitutes you know they come in
and they just want us for sex and things
like this and so when i began working
with
the new humanitarian thompson reuters
foundation and a team of journalists
like anchika song gosiifa bahati sam
mednick
we worked with trusted um local civil
society
sources and researchers to begin a sort
of trust building process with a number
of individual victims and indeed
individual victims were apprehensive for
quite a long period about talking to us
understandably so but after we talked to
the first people who described being
victimized in this way
um the women would say well actually i
know a lot of other people in my
workplace were hired like this who had
sex demanded of them before they were
employed
and so thus we sort of tapped into a
network
of victims who have shared experiences
or similar experiences and
we're able to build trust for them like
this and and what did you find in your
investigation
well we found really um across the two
investigations that we published
we spoke to more than 70 women
approximately 75 women
who described really horrific forms of
sexual exploitation and abuse
widespread practice especially in who
and other un agencies like unicef and
iom
of demanding sex in exchange for jobs a
number of instances of
women describing being raped a number of
instances of women describing
contracting venereal disease
diseases being impregnated um one
particular
particularly horrific instance of a
woman dying after
a dangerous sponged abortion a number of
instances of women being forced to seek
abortions from the individuals who
impregnated them
and overwhelmingly these individuals
being people working with the world
health organization
a number of other agencies a lot of
foreigners and so forth but people work
in the
working in the ebola response yeah right
um just
going into these cases let's look first
at for example
there were cases alleging rape
why didn't these women take these up uh
you know as legal
or criminal cases well um in particular
with respect to rape um
it's particularly horrific to not
dynamic but
for instance one of the women that we
spoke to was raped and after she was
raped she still hoped that she would be
employed
by who and indeed she was um and so that
sort of economic desperation
was certainly always a dynamic um
there's additionally the issue of the
fact that just generally speaking
um the sort of legal system in congo is
not especially effective and in
particular with respect to sexual
violence um sort of particularly
egregious and finally and most
importantly um women were very
apprehensive about going public because
of concerns about stigma from community
members in a number of cases women
hadn't even told their husbands
that they had been abused like this and
didn't want to start a protracted legal
process
and likewise feared facing um
retribution or
threats or something like this from the
people who had abused them in the first
place
in in our report that we we heard
earlier there was
desanj who is struggling to look after
her dead sister's
three children what chance do those
children have of getting any
compensation from
uh the who worker or even from the who
itself
you know unfortunately your guess is as
good as mine uh what we know
is what who has made public after our
initial investigation was published last
september
there was a media storm and who came
forward made the sort of standard
rhetorical commitments to zero tolerance
and said it would engage in
robust investigations after that period
eight months lapsed and it seemed that
there weren't any investigations
occurring on the ground eight to nine
months
later in may or june a team began
conducting investigations of what was
going on it's not clear what was
happening in any intervening period
and that team that is doing the work
it's not clear what their methodology is
it's not clear whether they would be who
would be willing to provide compensation
or psychological services to victims
none of this had been made has been made
clear there's been a total lack of
transparency
on w.h.o zen okay
journalist robert flummerfeldt in
bukharvu south kivu province in the drc
thank you very much for
explaining that to us